we have a tradition around our office
during the holidays it's our annual
holiday sweater contest something we've
been doing for years it's where our
staff competes to see who has the most
festive holiday sweater and for the last
five years it has come down to a heated
battle between Devin in research and
Barbara in makeup these two they take it
really seriously so we thought this year
would bring out our competitors and let
the audience decide the winner they've
been working really hard on their
sweaters is that cool with you guys if
we show you thank you thank you Tony
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
finalists in the 2015 Conan staff
holiday sweater pageant Devin and
Barbara
[Music]
[Applause]
all right look at these letters ice work
guys let's start with you Barbara tell
us a little bit about your sweater first
I've sewn over 200 LED lights into the
fabric with these high visibility lights
grandma will never get run over by the
reindeer remember that song not really
and what about what about Santa there my
nephew Zach the one with the extra toes
designed this fully animatronic Santa
with voice recognition check this out I
love you Santa oh you're smothering me
Barbara
that's incredible plus my sweaters got
its own built-in holiday train
[Applause]
mistletoe antenna want to help me break
it in no I don't
best of luck Barban you'll need it
because it looks like Devon brought his
AGame here Devon is that what I think it
is well if you think it's a completely
edible gingerbread sweater decorated
with over 15 pounds of hand placed candy
and frosting then yes that's exactly
what it is that is impressive yeah and
check it out to wash all the gingerbread
down the sleeves dispense eggnog and hot
cocoa check it out oh it's really great
but you know I have to say Devon I don't
mean to be unkind but you seem to put on
some weight yeah what happened I don't
know how that happened okay well there
you have it our two finalists for the
Conan staff holiday sweater
[Music]
her what is that heavenly sound that I
hear why it is the greatest holiday
sweater of all time an entire children's
choir sewn into a sweater worn by Conan
O'Brien behold
[Music]
[Applause]
we bring for you and your kin good
tidings for Christmas and a Happy New
Year we wish you a Merry Christmas we
wish you a Merry Christmas we wish you a
Merry Christmas and a happy new
[Applause]
Tonino
[Applause]
all inhale I got diabetes for nothing
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography